what's going on everyone it's the true
Geordi but again and last Friday I was
doing something at the st. Mary's
Stadium commenting on a game between two
teams of youtubers sideman FC and the
YouTube all-stars they were made up with
some of the biggest youtubers in the
country people you might have heard of
like ksi Spencer all in my power up done
plenty with before jor-el are people
like that and it was all in the name of
charity they raised over a hundred
thousand pounds for charity and I'll put
the link in the description below if you
want to get involved one or more but
just out of [__] great day to be
honest it was a really good time I'm on
commentary
I love commenting I don't comment it
like although commentator so I just take
the piss which basically want to do on
this [__] channel and you look old
used to live by you know my demographic
is I you know in the late teens to like
in the late thirties you all you're all
mature you all know what this is I don't
take it seriously it's just a piss taken
[__] however we have some of the massive
audiences like these youtubers are
pulling in five million people watch
this game within 24 hours that is more
than the Champions League but I didn't
take it quite as seriously as the
gigantic final as you can imagine and
some of the the younger audience were
slightly offended which did nothing but
encourage this [__] to take the piss
Ethan Mobile so I wanted to let you see
some of the highlights of what went on
unfortunately I can't let you see me and
the lads all up on the piss together I
was the last month on and as you can
imagine I think I was up with all four
in the morning how they plan to catch
two hours after I had my last drink so
not a clever decision to make but what
you can't see that later is me and my
mate Lawrence McKenna just basically
sitting having a laugh and take the piss
whale watching some football so hope you
have a good time watching it cuz I had a
[__] good time making it oh yeah and
anyone who wants to mourn about how I
did just remember didn't have any squad
sheets didn't have any numbers list
didn't have a good camera to see the
[__] plans so on all things drugs say
that I think I did all right
right so like the video and stay
subscribed they are the type of lads who
if you had a sister that's who you'd
want to Lamar
especially because after Joe showed
released our booth probably got a bit
but bit of money behind them is missing
ceremony cash back maybe I can sponge
off Larry and that's what I'm thinking
Murray him and then I'll live off the
profits people that's all does sit on
the pitch you can't see that right now I
don't think but just a toy like this is
this it's sort of it's like that like
that this is kind of embarrassing if we
can to maybe this would be a good time
to let everyone know that I have a
youtube channel called the true Geordie
YouTube channel you know make sure if
you've got the time in between the match
night and now I mean if any feel free
time to go to subscribe cuz I look at
painfulness I'm doing this out of the
goodness of my heart because I love
charity I love people but if you want to
make me feel good about that
then by all means subscribe I mean who
would I be to say no yeah it's a regular
you know I mean yeah I've risked my life
coming down to South Hampton from
Newcastle to see people the job to
Southampton
I'm bike at the South Auckland I've got
on a plane we all know that planes can
be deadly
I risk my life so at least subscribe
that's all I'm saying that's the minimum
that is the middle and if you do so let
me know and I'll send you something I'll
tell you what it may just be a pen or
something like that you know but the pen
is better than nothing
which is what I'm getting to do this so
just yeah enjoy enjoy the content but
it's back again with Chris MD Chris Andy
week and his way through it's true one
cool good down in the pocket check
families early dears let's watch wizzy
because easy he's a tricky one honey
badger here is he is a hero and he will
be absolutely loving it look at him he's
telling everyone
hi I'm King well this place look for
help
he's got the ceiling I was a lot with
shock it slowly over credit the bazinga
not scared not fright he took that shot
and it was an in many ways on a matter
pay ik bazinga as it left his foot he's
proud of his muscles as July's always
getting his top off at any opportunity
towards time don't really see anything
I'm just a little jealous that's the big
problem early with youtubers isn't it
Jordi's most them play computer games
and of course they can hit it off a lump
of metal called the crossbar
but are they that good in real life or
about to find out one thing I found
about youtubers is without someone to
edit videos down to make them look
better than what they actually are
they're not as good yeah fully all thing
yeah it is surprise to that oh sit down
these fellows georgg its ruling an ugly
me I'm sure this is completely genuine
yes this can't be often youtubers are
not that good at Upton no you know that
this is true what we've seen that from
his career so far
what our two year or easy buck up to a
standing ovation gets like a Ultimate
Warrior a sitting of it just as you
think he's dead he's back up yeah he's
sick in the room look at him you haven't
seen his child so far then maybe you
want to check it out check mine out
first yeah just true tool remember first
my then Chris anyone else
of course there's 22 people out there
all of them have YouTube channels going
take a look at them all they're all well
worth a look
not only first you know swept though by
Reuters Shaw wrote ashore managing their
to make something that was perfectly
simple look really difficult
fantastically does not quite a lot so
well yeah it's it just look better than
anyone else it's his greatest strength
Ari is the best at that I buy yourself a
man with a name that probably belongs in
Game of Thrones yes and probably a face
that belongs in Game of Thrones as well
Jules yeah look ma no one of those
princes one of those princes I could
imagine them brilliant you can imagine
him murdering a young Arthur that's what
I'm looking out there Geordi and I'm
seeing Marcus Butler I'm seeing some
other great young guys I'm thinking
YouTube's ruined some good football
careers I'm not so sure about that if
I'm honest no you're right yeah I was
just being trite I think I think phones
for you or any phone company for that
matter is really missing out on some
good sellers you know what does these
lads have got the putter [__] of
Ronaldinho at the World Cup
I'm sure sven-göran eriksson ass at home
right now must have it in furiously
watching this game
worried that many minutes chromatic 11
but at the same time still wondering why
Jared and Lampard couldn't work but who
was there to clean up that's the lad
with his own book Joe sugg Joe so
missing the kick the first time or
desorb book but managing to do it again
the second of course are a couple of
guys out there with their own book side
men launching a book later this year
head those are the captions below in
your lips I'm sure that'll be advertised
somewhere fantastically I'm pre-order
right nobody's asked me to write a book
or underworld
I've got I'm an addict dauntless I've
got stories to tell but nobody's
interested I try and tell them I thought
they always say who are you and I broke
there was people who are you you're not
GG go away cuz I'm in a talk it has a
very interesting running style there he
he runs like a horse that's been shot in
the arse Chris MD carries the ball so
beautifully doesn't he or do it's a low
center of gravity me you remind me of a
little Sergio agüero out there just only
prettier but it's no test for you is he
no not huge Hugh as they call him you
choke and that is strictly a body
perspective from height well I see we've
seen anything no regions well lure do we
want do yes or do we want even if we
have we wouldn't talk about that on this
day free boots for you to wear on your
YouTube channel
what's the name of that but my thought
is Everest it's the true Jordi YouTube
channel which is an appalling theory to
subscribe
Hughie's he looks like a proud 8 year
old with his own ball at the park he
looks like he's just got his report card
home from school and it's all is mama
mummy mummy come and read this he
shouted what is it what is it young Hugh
I got all A's mama I did it I did it
mama you'll be going to college no I'm
gonna be a youtuber you've disappointed
everyone Hugh wait mama one day I'm
gonna play in front of 15,000 people
then what though Hugh them what how'd
you put bread on the table there's
always a Ford Company who would thought
that to lots of teams who odd
professional footballers would be
struggling at this point
luckily yeah not blame it yeah that's a
very good point Geordie means like Steve
McClaren is managing both of them this
time and he's trying to work himself out
tying himself in knots to be honest he
probably would manage one of these
logically get a job for love nor money
at the moment but I told it that have
them clouds clay Joe Weller comes to
place the door laughs collects with a
ball did Akuma savor the game so far Wow
Wow look at you he ended his body like a
young lima would all a Stretch Armstrong
if anyone
those yeah my rent you a goalkeeper too
wild apparently that you know they like
a twisted genius you were just a little
bit too twisted he errantly mani was
bodying up to him well a lightning rod
is bodying I love the idea of two men
budding up men yet body to body skin on
skin yet stripped of the ways fight God
strips on me
forget about body the body will you I'm
interested to see what people are saying
into it so far Jordy maybe a half time
I'm going to I don't think they're gonna
be saying what a fantastic job or doing
loving at TV is in trouble to is the
film it people are bored of it you know
why cause old people decide what's on TV
believe in us don't leave is that the
boss
Oh Morgan lund just sent me a private
message on their Twitter saying you're
the most [__] annoying commentator
ever Morgan thank you go [__] yourself
Morgan I know Jordy I've made it quite
clear that I can now receive a lot of
messages on Twitter and there are many
coming through football mate ignore the
hate comments oh great oh I'm literally
I'm receiving hundreds of messages at
once please kill yourself
are you unbearable cut I've got a lot to
thank the southern France for actually
because they've got me well used to this
six skinned as I'm being told chance to
FIFA Toby mani is it money me David the
NH has conceded you've done something
bad
you've committed a crime you want to
ease your conscience you've done
something you regret
no Nate the charity God might forgive
you yeah but I don't know anywhere god I
might forget YouTube all-stars Lauren
danger of capitulate yeah as miniman de
cook so on the right hand side
fascinated across it in its in isn't it
surely you began its God go crazy you
you saw this coming
I seen this coming a [__] mile off me
there's another f-bomb for charity every
time I say [__] I have to donate so [__]
[__] [__] [__]
let's donate some moment let's get that
money raised and the crop the Crowder
chugging look good for it
look maybe see a true Jordan true Jordy
and something tells like that so you
know so feel a little for kneel down in
front of thirteen thousand people and
millions upon to again me it's true
again and this is it it's true it it
goes oh the poor bored backyard who you
chew off stars or look seeing time a
last minute inclusion in this game he
come dim can't become that he came in
for the burnt [__] and he's delivered
he's delivered he come down any Camden
income right at the right time yes all
over I've met nicely all the Portsmouth
skin already scared to come up
this is communist
oh what a cold sore that is that is
class Sato book Newcastle Oh him he was
he celebrated so for me but he's getting
across in all this could be r4 Jawa he
turns on his left foot
oh just grazing from Hugh wizzy as he
pushes away a beautiful Joe well a shot
powerful accurate Chili's plays would
you've given birthday I probably would
have given birth to humors it yeah he
would have been at the emails I never
wanted but loved any magic Hugh busy
covered in your percent X I luckily I
don't have a room so there's no chance
of me doing that that's right don't
think I'll get a sugar baby at my team
anytime soon
what is going on in the box yeah it's
all kicking off I just want to see the
best mate that's all I'm here for the
best the best of what essentially is
players who aren't very good at football
so obviously the best of those you may
notice that your teeth are chattering so
mater you look slightly cool I am cold
ten stone dripping wet as our Lawrence
and he is freezing on a sunny day and so
Dublin just a little word of advice
don't come away in Newcastle like the
cardigan mini mint it ball goes through
any releasing the metals the next mini
myth that I really thought that you had
had got the humiliating the goalkeeper
Briana is available
I'm so
well the cream has risen to the Tollison
the cream has risen to the top and
Joella is overjoyed he deserves that
cool yeah he's been breaking his heart
trying to score like all good luck in
many ways he's like a young Eddie yeah
confirm one in many ways is absolutely
nothing like our Tea Act ephemera was
that is that plant is this real
was that everything no that's real like
mini Minter has scored a hat-trick is
this real life edits at the back of the
live from the whole flailing mini-mental
boudoir probably couldn't have done that
let me fail no he's trying to ball quite
well hey that is that's a perfect
hat-trick from Robert Cobb believe this
make you miss Linda is going for a pro
ble contractor people are buying a lot
about Rushford what about this kid get
him on the plane to the heroes Roy get
him on the what's up blood that didn't
happen here is he because we might have
seen a man explode yeah yeah this would
have been like the shootin Illinois he
pulls out a knee okay that just says
goes crazy everyone who witnessed this
will all die today
yeah and we promote open up joke the
problems will be torture we're left to
commentate them I will remind you it's
just okay to go to the Just Giving page
it's worth it just give up just whatever
you got awfully low cool I've just lost
the [__] pop did that desert them
yeah oh no oh no don't tell me Chris
ideas now the baby-faced assassin profit
goes over any wobble Chrissy to apply
some pressure not Chrissy people we are
seeing images of Chris MD with they're
in distress
well no I mean he look he's got cramps
saw he's alright he's like you know
everyone he's up he's up what's up is
that the door I touch it the crowd cheer
I don't think I could hear ever handle
that anything up the Chris I wouldn't
want to live not mine Chris I was a
little Chrissy well Jamie's pushed off
the ball again Jamie's been great upon
you got penalties first one
totally you got a juggle you got to stop
this comeback with you you got to shut
it now or never let me down David Leon
hitch us hit the ball straight a few is
he who is he's had two easy saves there
but he's still it's amazing Georgie
lives me to penalty seems I don't care
what you say that is fantastic
Wow but all I can say is Lawrence such
yeah Rigsby that's this is he or you are
you message is cool Wow Wow
oh my god please shut the [__] up worse
commentator ever Wow get Jordy to sing
will Griggs on fire a neutral it's
mutual sorry Oh meet rose or Maya no
differences there are my neutrals on
fire if they do happen to make a song
out of that what the [__] royalties
I'm just saying Shan says shortly stops
off today Alex right normal freebies
right but be charitable while it's still
today alright that is love that control
from Zynga is like watching Q through
it's going to go all the way this is
pissing us chugs field like the hero oh
he was on cell loss you've seen them go
all the way unselfish George saw
unselfish just like you should big be
unselfish donut that's all I'm saying go
to the Just Giving page fall or person
goes example you've got their attention
their get their attention if you're
looking at the cop if you're looking at
the description box below and you'll see
you're saying that there is no just
giving link here there is sometimes the
complaint will be false yes exactly that
is full time of the youtubers run off
the pitch
really welcome all of them winners and
losers they're all winners everybody's
on the pitch think it's all over on the
pitch it is now give a monkey's all the
way so now storming the tunnel
I've stubbed a few tunnels of my time
you see someone everyone in the changing
rooms in the dressing rooms
we need horde or all the doll or the
doll and that is coming at the
Chancellor Kaya thyself that is a sad
fair the great state are you busy then
hello oh all the bar I know he sees them
will in this game yeah that should be me
yeah it should be
people bowing down over people forward
towards your bells out Jordan absolutely
remember nicely Mohammed olesya were
coming out thanks for coming out dog
come up you do not even ok yeah I like
to see I you see you but I don't don't
want to mix oh come near him please
leave me alone leave me alone
look luckily no one came for us mate but
because we're such big celebrities on
YouTube so many subscribers that they
thought best to stay away it was no
point or God wouldn't even approach them
the laptop EULA would be bother I'm
believe that the hazing as eyes up 30
minutes Jordi wouldn't even approach him
the doctor at SEMA on that beautiful
piece of silver who's going to look
Patrick look at that they're taking a
shot there and it is held fine it is a
fantastic Oh
move that cover up quick I've gone off
the cameraman secret of the right I'm
yes he's on the right thing now a lot of
people have said Jordi you're not ready
for the big boys you'll already done I
told you you're not ready for 18 what I
say check me out now on the site and
check me out now don't need just
side man better views anyway yes he good
look for the side man a good look for
anyone thank you so we got the load
stretcher it's time to patient's it's
time for the presentation [__]
[__] was what the talk is then ghost
is just giving page below and you indeed
can give money today also have a moment
yeah because given as you'll find at
some point in their life is also just as
far as receiving so key
generously that's all I will say yes go
for it enjoy fill your boots get stuck
in I believe you said that one giving
and receiving before just go for it me
just cause